[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'âge de 24 ans pour réaliser un rêve
de voyager autour de l'europe
j'ai travaillé comme plongeur en
angleterre j'étais pas dans la
prestigieuse ville de londres
j'étais dans un petit village rural où
il y avait plus de moutons que
d'habitants et 15 e 10 plongeurs je
faisais pas de la plongée sous-marine je
l'avais de la vaisselle dans un
restaurent et regarder l'image peut voir
tout de suite que mon rêve s'est
rapidement transformée en cauchemar
j'avais l'impression que ma patronne
mais même pas en fait c'est faire des
choses étranges comme un éléphant du
bourg sous la pluie où il y avait le
plancher de la cuisine avec une brosse à
dents comme dans les contes pour enfants
son départ je trouvais ça gros je m'en
moquais avec mes collègues
avec le temps ça se transformer en
plainte parce que je trouvais plus drôle
du tout je me rappelle encore la pire
des fois j'étais tranquillement dans la
cuisine en train d'essuyer ma vaisselle
quand il ya deux cuisiniers commence à
chicaner de parler vraiment fort la
patronne arrive en courant dans la
cuisine puis à cherche le coupable des
yeux alors qu'il ya tout le monde dans
la pièce jusqu'à tant qu'à cruz mongai a
dit simon tu vois qu'il a fermé je pense
vous avez déjà vécu une situation des
bus ou d'injustice mais moi je vous
parlais comme j'ai vécu ça je me sentis
humiliés devant tous mes collègues
j'avais absolument rien à voir avec
cette situation là j'avais honte
j'avais juste envie de me mettre à
petite boule dans un coin qui pleurait
je voulais que personne n'en parle mais
personne ne me voit que j'avais
tellement une question demain matin je
me dis pourquoi s'acharne sur moi
pourquoi je tolère ça qu'est ce que je
peux changer bien des choses mais je me
rappelle je me suis dit en tout cas une
chose qui est sûre si jamais je venais
quand elle a des comportements abusifs
comme cela je veux jamais faire subir ça
à personne en disant ça j'ai eu une
prise de conscience
j'ai appelé mon petit frère mais pas
pour me plaindre pour m'excuser je
voulais m'excuser pour toutes les fois
que j'avais levé le ton avec lui pour
toutes les fois que j'avais était abusif
envers lui je comprenais maintenant quel
point ça faisait mal
puis je voulais lui dire qu'ils se
laissent plus jamais jamais parlé comme
son parti que ce soit ça allait
commencer par mois à partir de
maintenant
ce jour là j'ai appris la première leçon
pour cultiver un climat très positif et
c'est la responsabilité de mes actions
et des impacts qu'ils ont sur les autres
j'ai réalisé que j'avais manqué de
respect à mon frère mais j'avais aussi
manqué de respect à ma patronne à
chacune des fois que je mettais moquer
d'elle ou que je mettais plein et dans
son dos dalphond j'avais probablement
contribué au climat négatif qui règne à
mon travail
ça fait mal de réaliser cela c'est
toujours le jeu aussi pris la décision
de changer mon comportement au travail
et dans les semaines qui ont suivi la
relation avec ma patronne s'est
grandement améliorée fait les années
suivantes
j'ai occupé divers emplois qui ont varié
entre 6 à 18 mois
je pense que je te libérer a jamais de
climat négatif comme j'avais vécu en
angleterre j'ai réalisé que ce n'est pas
aussi simple que ça je me suis retrouvé
dans des situations similaires mais avec
des visages différents
par curiosité lever la main si vous avez
déjà quitté un emploi à cause de la
relation avec votre patron
on appris de la moitié de la salle
ceux qui ont levé la main garder l'âme
élevé et maintenant garder l'âme élevé
seulement si vous avez dit le fond de
votre pensée à votre patron avant de
quitter votre emploi ou à il reste plus
beaucoup de m'élever je pose la question
parce que je me suis moi-même privé
longtemps de parler il ya quelques
années je me suis retrouvé dans un poste
de leadership en vente il je me sentais
complètement ensevelie sous la création
des demandes
j'avais beau faire du mieux que je
pouvais pour m'organiser pour répondre à
toutes mes obligations
mais dès que je recevais une demande
pour fournir un rapport dernière minute
j'avais des sueurs froides j'avais des
palpitations cardiaques chantait ma
pression monte
pire encore je ressentais une boule dans
le ventre qu'il fallait que je transfère
ces demandes-là aux membres de mon
équipe qui sentait tout aussi débordés
que moi imaginez
la cascade de stress qui se répandait au
sein de mon équipe
pas super positif comme kim au travail
il fallait que ça change
il fallait que ça change c'est une
question de survie qu'est ce que je peux
changer je voulais pas quitter mon
emploi gênait la compagnie je voulais
pas abandonner un membre de mon équipe
et je savais aussi que fuir la situation
ça réglerait pas mon problème à janet
fallait que je parle avec mon patron et
pourquoi c'est si difficile de parler
choses comme ça sont au boss
j'avais pris une part j'avais la gorge
série ça me brûlait andin il fallait que
ça sorte
je partage avec vous comment j'ai
organisé mon message pour pas que ça
dérape en trois éléments
première chose juillet dit j'observe les
faits le nombre de courriels que je
reçois l'instant si ils tant que je
perds
il tente mon équipe perd à répondre à
toutes ces demandes là je l'expliquais
les paquets rien que ça mais sur notre
focus une perte de productivité
ensuite je vais partager ce que je
ressens je nomme les émotions qui me
rongeait à l'intérieur je ressens la
frustration je reste la culpabilité
je ressens un manque de confiance
ça m'empêche de dormir la nuit
ça n'est pas que la qualité mon travail
je terminais en lui disant ce que
j'aimerais parce que je voulais pas
juste me plaindre je voulais fournir une
solution
j'aimerais tune fasse confiance
j'aimerais qu'on élimine des rapports
sont inutiles à mes yeux
j'aimerais un peu plus de reconnaissance
pour moi c'est sympa se rappeler aura
trois lettres le sentiment que j'ai
ressenti kg tout dit
c'est comme si je venais de lenche et un
sac à dos rempli de roche que je
traînais depuis des mois au et quand
j'ai entendu sa réponse
j'étais surpris d'apprendre que mon
patron il n'y avait aucune idée que je
me sentais comme ça puis c'était
certainement pas son intention de me
faire sentir comme ça il m'a même dit
qu'ils apprécient vraiment laquelle tu
es mon travail mais le plus important
il me confier comment lui sentait les
défis que lui vivaient les comptes
qu'ils avaient à revendre avec son
patron
j'ai réalisé qu'il se sentait comme moi
fait que cette conversation le sincère
nous a vraiment permis de comprendre la
réalité drôle de l'autre puis trouver
une meilleure façon travailler ensemble
ce jour là j'ai réalisé
j'ai appris la deuxième leçon pour que
tu me lis motard est positif et c'est
l'authenticité
quand je dis le fonds n'a pas là c'est
ce que je ressens vraiment en toute
vulnérabilité
je connecte avec l'humain au delà du
lien hiérarchique séance disaient les
vraies choses donc qu'on peut créer un
meilleur climat de travail
ça m'a même permis d'abord un peu de
reconnaissance cette conversation le
lever la main ceux qui aimeraient savoir
un peu plus de reconnaissance dans le
travail
c'est assez assez unanime j'ai reçu une
carte de remerciement un jour pour avoir
développé un nouvel outil
et puis j'ai gardé la carte à cause de
la citation de gandhi qui avait sur le
dessus que je trouvais très inspirante
vous devez incarner le changement que
vous souhaitez voir dans le monde
je dois incarner le changement que je
veux voir dans le monde
donc si je veux voir plus de
reconnaissance autour de moins ça doit
commencer par moi qui en donne en
premier j'ai donc commencé à donner des
médailles pour souligner les meilleures
performances déjà on sait mon équipe
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une soif pour ce
genre de reconnaissance là donc j'ai
ajouté des mentions spéciales pour aussi
souligné la qualité du travail puis
avait un engouement positif tellement
fort aux et mon équipe je me suis dit je
peux pas arrêter juste là je veux faire
un effort conscient pour souligner le
travail de mes collègues et des manques
donc département ça pouvait être un
appel pour dire merci sophy d'avoir fait
ça pour mon équipe
bravo vincent pour tes réalisations un
geste aussi simple que trente deux
minutes pour dire à quelqu'un son
travail est important et ça m'a toujours
surpris de voir l'impact positif
la troisième et dernière leçon que j'ai
apprise pour cultiver un climat très
positif c'est la reconnaissance ainsi
gestes simples pour souligner le travail
bien fait salon une énorme impact
positif sur tous les gens autour de moi
ce sont des membres de mon équipe
des collègues ou même mon patron est la
meilleure façon de décrire l'effet que
celle de données de la reconnaissance
données de la reconnaissance
c'est comme donner de l'eau à quelqu'un
d'assoiffés dans le désert
c'est tellement désaltère somme toute au
fil de toutes ces expériences depuis mon
ailleurs depuis mon emploi en angleterre
j'ai pris conscience que j'ai le pouvoir
d'influencé mon clim au travail que
choix dans un rôle d'employé où que je
sois dans un rôle de leader
j'ai le pouvoir d'influencé mon climat
de travail dans le doute je me repose la
question qu'est ce que je peux changer
imaginez si chacun d'entre nous prenez
l'entière responsabilité de ces paroles
de ses actions de ses émotions
imaginez si vous osez dire le fond de
votre pensée avec authenticité avec
votre patron
imaginez si vous donniez un peu plus de
reconnaissance à vos proches au
quotidien quel serait l'impact positif
dans vos relations au travail et vos
amis votre famille dans votre couple
avec vos enfants
quels changements désirés voir dans
votre monde
merci
[Applaudissements]